[Musique]
et voilà vous y êtes de lait très très
bien monsieur merci Jean de grève
mobilisation quand on a réforme des
retraites la 9e doit-onloter la
bienvenue au téléspectateurs de
Télématin je sais pas
vous allez découvrir un autre univers
des frontal en cuisine ce restaurant
gastronomique a choisi une action
symbolique
éteindre la lumière le temps d'une
soirée pour dénoncer la flambée des prix
de l'énergie
une initiative insolite du chef
Christophe Marc
vous servir malgré tout dans la vraie
cuisine et des vrais plats chauds voilà
bon appétit et bonne soirée à tous
l'électricité monte le gasoil Nokia on
va faire des caddie on a des familles
qui aujourd'hui sont obligées de se
rationner ça on fait confiance au chef
on peut dîner les yeux fermés c'est pas
grave
c'est justement pour ne pas rompre cette
confiance que la profession n'envisage
pas d'augmenter l'addition impensable de
répercuter la hausse du coup de
l'électricité sur le client comment vous
estimez qu'on peut se sortir de cette
crise
on voit bien qu'ils sont tous solidaires
ils sont tous à la bonne gamelle comme
on dit hein il profite de tout
gouvernement et puis repartir sur de
bonnes bases d'après le journal son
arrivée en mai 2022 déjà la première
ministre s'en était plainte je suis à la
tête d'un gouvernement à moitié composé
de débiles voilà ce que leur a dit bon
depuis isabelle a démenti on tenait à
vous remercier ça a été vraiment super
vous avez fait un excellent travail
mille merci c'est magnifique
erreur je me dis peut-être qu'il y aura
une épiphanie peut-être que si ça se
trouve c'est le roi d'Angleterre qui va
venir donner des conseils de démocratie
voire de République au président en lui
disant ben nous on a une monarchie mais
quand même c'est pas une monarchie
absolue bon ben le pantalon ça tombait
et vous finalement c'était dégueulasse
vraiment c'était minable evidemment les
photos que je vous montre sont
absolument fausses et truquées mais ce
ne sont pas des voilà il a mis un peu
dans les cortèges ce ne sont pas des
photos montages d'un internaute si vous
voulez ce sont des montages réalisés par
une intelligence artificielle c'est une
machine un mot pour définir son
intervention d'hier hors sol il aurait
mieux fait de se taire arrogante nul le
président de la République se comporte
comme un casseur il fait le pari de la
violence pour faire passer sa réforme
vous êtes toujours pas d'accord mais non
il faudrait qu'on nous écoute voilà
parce que moi hier à midi j'avais pas
très envie d'écouter puisque je me sens
pas écouté vous connaissez chat gipiti
bon la version image c'est mes journées
vous vouliez j'ai testé ce matin vous
dites imagine et après vous mettez ce
que vous voulez imaginez Emmanuel Macron
en train de ramasser les poubelles et
bien hop il vous met email macontre en
ramasser les poubelles qui sont les
factieux est-ce que c'est nous ou qui
est-ce qui se font la nation la
République on nous dit bah voilà c'est
c'est quoi la France pour lui c'est un
joujou qui peut cacher
le sentiment je vous le dis oui une
espèce de monarchie absolue où tous les
pouvoirs sont aujourd'hui entre les
mains d'un seul homme les Français font
d'abord faudrait lui dire que les
Français c'est un F majuscule mais bon
ces gens-là
visiblement ils ont pas appris
l'orthographe les Français vont venir
vous chercher vous dégagez là il parle à
Emmanuel Macron comme l'a dit Olivier
matheux vous allez la manger votre
réforme député de la République il a été
viennent me chercher ça m'a fait vous
allez aussi Macron
vous allez c'est c'est c'est là on est
en CM2 mais bon
comme ces étudiants en grandes écoles
il ne peut pas regarder des films
violents je me retrouve dans la rue
tellement en colère
pense que la violence est
malheureusement nécessaire
moi il y en a une qui fait bien rire
c'est l'avocat et la Carole lever ces
choses-là
pardon monsieur allez ramasser les
poubelles c'est autant votre boulot que
le mien et c'est autant non mais
attendez comment ça c'est autant mon
boulot que le vôtre
sur les talons aiguilles on s'en passera
pardon c'était une vraie question
voulez-vous coucher avec moi ce soir
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de l'invention du jour c'est
une nouvelle intelligence artificielle
appelée cupidesbot et qui pointe le bout
de son nez c'est intelligence
artificielle permet d'interagir avec les
utilisatrices sur des applications de
rencontre en sélectionnant les profils
compatibles et en ayant des
conversations à votre place ça c'est
génial grâce à elle fini les prises de
tête pour trouver la bonne disquette de
drague en quelques messages et là pour
but de charmer votre cible et
d'organiser un rendez-vous avec elle
je rappelle que je pourrais être votre
père alors allons-y vous ne l'êtes pas
justement non non
c'est vrai
mais il y a eu une espèce de barrière si
vous voulez c'est bien c'est bien
la question éthique de la transparence
vis-à-vis de l'utilisation des chatbots
et soulevé les femmes n'étant pas
informées
et dans mon refuge de rêve où vous êtes
tout est apaisé et tout va bien
je loupe le ballon
je crois que tu as voulu shooter le
gazon
moi même je rigole tellement c'est nul
oh là là j'ai même par gentillesse je
vous ai tellement demandé qu'on devienne
potes que vous avez accepté de me faire
jouer dans Léo Mattéi c'est-à-dire